end of the world was upon us would you
be
ready today people all over America are
stocking extensive amounts of food water
and
ammunition expecting that at any moment
a devastating disaster will strike these
people are called Preppers I'm preparing
for the second worldwide Great
Depression for the collapse of society
due to PCO for a worldwide
pandemic okay we all know a prepper no
matter how extreme
you might have a disaster kit packed or
emergency Plies ready or even an entire
compound to escape to but more people
including young people are getting ready
for the next big disaster a survey from
the financial services company finder
earlier this year reveals that 40% of
genz and 39% of Millennials are spending
money on prepping that's up from around
25% in 2017 and about a third of all
adults have have spent an average of
$150 on emergency items like food water
and of course medical supplies but there
are some people who go really big like
my next guest joining me now is Colonel
Drew Miller CEO and manager of the
survival facility fortitude Ranch I love
the name of it drew um I know you have
multiple compounds that people can go to
in an
emergency um and and I want to hear all
about that but first tell us what the
biggest concern concerns people have are
now is this covid related or is there a
concern about an EMP cutting out all
internet what's going
on well Preppers who are watching for
threats paying attention to them were
recently surveyed was published in the
Washington examiner and they identified
five of the top threats number one was a
grid down our electric grid is very
vulnerable uh number two was a
bioengineered virus or bio attack that
could cause a really deadly pandemic not
not covid but you know h5n1 60% lethal
type pandemic the other one was the
Civil War next year A lot of people are
concerned that we are so divided as a
nation that we could have a civil war
next year Ray Delo has actually
predicted that uh fourth one was an
economic collapse that could lead to a
loss of Law and Order a collapse and
then the last one was terrorist attacks
because of our largely open
borders well when when you think about
let's just start with one thing
the grid going down like we've all seen
the films and you know the Obama Obama's
new Netflix uh movie about this it shows
what happens to one family and one
Community migration patterns of animals
loss of ability to move to travel all of
that I is that your major concern given
what we're
seeing yeah well prepit is number one
and it's it's our Achilles heal as a
nation and it's not just Russia or China
who could take out our grid a small
terrorist group could do with physical
and cyber attacks North Korea with their
lousy inaccurate small nuclear force
could readily take down the US Electric
System and we had reports intelligence
reports I'm a Former Intelligence
officer I'm not telling you something
secret this was published in the papers
that Russia helped them design their
nuclear force optimizing it for EMP
electromagnetic pulse effect and a
congressionally funded study study DMP
warned that you could lose 90% % of
Americans when North Korea takes down
our grid be down for over a year it's
not just no electricity no Municipal
Water Systems so most Americans will die
when that happens we've known about it
for decades and Congress has done
absolutely nothing to fix it because
there's no reelection votes in preparing
for Homeland Security well at least
Ukraine will be okay all right let's
let's talk about um your fortitude Ranch
and what happens there how does it help
prepare people or give people a place to
go to in a in a severe
emergency well we're we're survival
facility so in Good Times our members
can come here and recreate and vacation
but when the hits the fan and that's
actually the term Preppers use shtf when
that happens uh we turn into survival
community so we have staff like myself
and Ranch managers in charge but all of
our members have weapons the weapons
that President Biden and Governor Nome
would like to ban uh we've got weapons
and we have prepared defensive positions
walls and we can defend ourselves and
survive in any kind of a grid down P
pandemic or any bad situation we can
survive wi without water you can't
survive long so water is the number one
thing a water source is the number one
thing that you would need
correct correct and that's easy for us
we're in rural location so we have wells
Creeks you know reservoirs of water we
have a lot of natural spring at several
of our locations uh but if you're in a
big city or even a suburb uh water alone
is going to be something that may be the
difference between life and death for
you drew I think a lot of people don't
want to think of you know this happening
or the possibility of this happening you
don't want to you know oh you're a
conspiracy theorist but you're glad that
you actually thought of things
contingencies when they happen and they
do happen uh I think it's fascinating
and I think it's you know being prepared
and being vigilant is always the right
call uh thank you so much for joining us
and sharing your
insights well thank you I appreciate the
opportunity hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else